why is a muggle wielding a wand what
lurks within the room of requirement
keep watching for all the secrets hiding
in the latest fantastic beasts trailer
one of the opening shots of the trailer
shows newt scamander and his brother
theseus strolling through a snowy
village of two houses with even taller
chimneys this is very clearly hogsmeade
a small village on the outskirts of
hogwarts which is home to a number of
little shops and several pubs like the
three broomsticks and the hogs head in
it's certainly not the first time the
village has shown up in the wizarding
world franchise as it is first
introduced in harry potter and the
prisoner of azkaban hogwarts students
have to get permission from their
parents or guardians to visit hogsmeade
on their days off but harry doesn't get
his form signed by the dursleys that's
why fred and george weasley give the boy
who lived the marauders map in the third
film which he uses to sneak down to
hogsmeade through one of the secret
passages out of hogwarts castle it's
interesting that hogsmeade is newt and
theseus's first port of call rather than
hogwarts but clearly their latest
mission is a dangerous one luckily they
find someone there who's able to point
them in the right direction
newton theseus wind up in the hogs head
in and meet aberthoth dumbledore who is
played by richard coyle this isn't the
first time coyle's career has steered
him toward a magical world as fans will
recognize him as a villainous father
blackwood from netflix's chilling
adventures of sabrina which also follows
witches and warlocks aberforth
previously appeared in the order of the
phoenix where he's played by jim mcmanus
but kieran hinz took over the role when
aberforth who is albus dumbledore's
brother reappeared in deathly hallows
part 2. amber fourth is clearly happier
with a much quieter life as a bartender
rather than albus dumbledore's antics
with dark wizards and that attitude is
clear in the trailer as well have to
save the world are we of course it isn't
surprising that the wizarding world
series is fleshing out dumbledore's
family since the sequel is literally
called the secrets of dumbledore let's
not forget that the previous film the
crimes of grindelwald reveals that
credence bare bone is actually aurelius
dumbledore oh dear this family reunion
is gonna get messy
we first see fantastic beasts villain
grindelwald now played by mass mickelson
after he replaced johnny depp in the
role he appears to be extracting the
memory of the wizard youssef karma the
memory extraction spell has popped up
regularly throughout the harry potter
series it's been used by dumbledore in
the past and was also deployed in
fantastic beasts and where to find them
on catherine waterstone's character tina
goldstein when she's brought to the
death cell wizards or witches who use
the spell will often store the memories
for later review using what's known as a
pensive why grindelwald needs karma's
memories isn't clear but we know from
the crimes of grindelwald that karma is
from an ancient pure blood wizarding
family so who knows what secrets he
might have
one magical creature above all that has
played a significant part in the corner
of the wizarding world we muggles i've
been lucky enough to see is the elusive
phoenix seen halfway through the teaser
the bird on fire swoops over the head of
credence bare bone with its wingtips
slightly lit
according to newt scamander's book
fantastic beasts and where to find them
phoenix's nest at the top of mountain
peaks suggesting that bare bones has
climbed to this snowy cliff face in
search of one the only concern is for
what reason given the bird's numerous
magical properties phoenix tears possess
powerful healing properties as shown in
harry potter and the chamber of secrets
not only that but any wizard who is
lucky enough to have a phoenix feather
at the center of their wand is a force
to be reckoned with two feathers
belonging to dumbledore's own phoenix
fox eventually wound up in the ones of
two of history's most powerful wizards
harry potter and lord voldemort keeping
that in mind could creedence's new
encounter actually be the bird that will
end up under the protection of
dumbledore himself we're getting fired
up to find out
the rumor of requirement is one of the
most fascinating parts of harry potter
law house elf dobby tells harry about
the secret room which only appears when
a person is in great need of it it
doesn't appear on any maps even the
marauders map and cannot be found unless
you know exactly what you are looking
for the room was later used by
dumbledore's army in harry potter and
the deathly hallows when neville
longbottom and other members hid out
there after death eaters infiltrated
hogwarts and now the room of requirement
is back
what is this place the room we require
we will have to wait though to see
exactly what this group requires from
the room and what that big spinning
cylinder thing is
halfway through we see one of the most
shocking moments of the trailer jacob
kowalski a muggle is given a wand
dumbledore said i give you something
are you kidding me right now
as any potter fan knows the wand chooses
the wizard though and jacob isn't even a
wizard so how does he have a wand most
likely it's a fake the plot of the
secrets of dumbledore focuses on
grindelwald's desire to destroy the
mughal race this means that during any
encounter with grindelwald or his
followers jacob would be especially at
risk building a wand as a clever way to
disguise jacob's non-magical abilities
and dumbledore likely planned this this
theory is further evidenced by the final
scene of the trailer showing jacob
eating in the great hall with some
hogwarts students and refusing to hand
it over to a student at which you might
be able to out him as a phony check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite wizards are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one